you had problems with managers in your
career because sometimes people have a
manager sometimes and they get along
great sometimes not so much I've had a
couple managers they're kind of shifty
when you're starting out like these guys
kind of control your career when I was a
young comedian I had a manager back in
New York and I was sleeping this is like
late 90s I was sleeping on my buddy's
floor I was just coming up no money to
be on my friend's floor literally and I
had a manager at the time and so I was
kind of grinding as a comedian and then
my buddy called me up Jeff Ross you know
Jeffrey Ross into the roastmaster
comedians awesome he called me up and
said good buddy because I'm doing this
gig he helped me write some jokes he'll
give you 200 bucks and I go yeah sure go
to Jeff's house he gives me 200 bucks in
cash and then my manager at the time
sent me a bill and commissioned it and
it wasn't a gig that he got me he just
found out that I did it and he just sent
me a bill for 20 bucks yeah it's so
shifty I was like you need $20 I'm
sleeping on a floor it's like come on
man things have turned around very
nicely for you yeah okay I mean in the
20 bucks you got it like that still be
looking for it
you